thank you Yasser yes we are here indeed
with Gabriel petrescu the vice president
of the Superbad Foundation Gabrielle
first of all welcome to the show tell us
a bit about your first uh thank you very
much ideas about the organization of uh
this event how do you enjoy it uh so I
enjoy it very much I mean I I came to
the foundation
from the very beginning in 2019 when uh
we we set up the foundation and it was
uh so wonderful that from the from the
start we uh we have been involved in the
granches tour from the very beginning so
and for years in a row uh it was a it
was a great
experience the super PATH foundation has
a lot of initiative with youth tell us a
bit about the Hyundai Sonos yeah so we
have a lot of initiatives about youth we
are
sustaining grants in all sorts of
disciplines and Sports in education we
have two major same projects that we
have been developing in the in the past
years it's gold scholarships that is
helping
the youth from 14 to 18 years old in in
getting performance in sports and the
other Project important project that we
are funding is the the Gambit the
step-by-step Center for education is um
is supporting this uh this project this
initiative and we are a sponsored we are
funding it as a matter of fact and some
of these kids have actually had the
privilege of chatting with one Gary
Casper of not many days ago tell us a
bit about that indeed it was a very very
interesting meeting that that the
children from step-by-step Center as
well as the go scholarships held with
Gary Casper they had one hour meeting
and they were really challenging Gary
Casper of uh with a lot of questions and
what I like the most was the fact that
they were asking questions about how he
behaved when he was young as they are
now and uh that that triggered some
emotions this is how I felt it uh on on
Mr casparov's side and it was um it was
pretty interesting and also a lot to
learn about how to deal with uh how to
cope with losing a game and this was
this was a question from them how do you
cope with losing and then it was of
course another question how do you cope
with when you win and that was a
wonderful thing no absolutely and to be
able to be so intimate with Gary Casper
of one of the greatest chess players of
all time he's just an incredible
opportunity that you guys are offering
this young generation and you guys are
working with the Casper of Chess
Foundation yes in schools as well here
in Romania yes uh also with um with the
support of the the step-by-step Center
we we managed to translate the the books
that have been published by the Casper
Foundation it's called step by step
learning just step by step and there are
three manuals one is for kindergarten so
we we start from Early Childhood let's
say
the other is for children in the primary
school primary school and then there is
also a big manual for teachers in order
to learn how to use chess not only in
how to play chess but also how to use
chess as a way of life as a way of
learning other disciplines that are not
necessarily related to sports or to the
chess itself but and this is I think
maybe the most important of all I think
you guys have a great system taking this
young minds from the early stages and
taking them all the way to University
the college level and the professional
level after
congratulations and thank you very much
for everything you're doing thank you it
was a pleasure guys back to you thank
you Christian I was reminded during that
interview you know Gary being asked how
do you cope with a loss how do you cope
with a win and Magnus Carlson the
depressed conference in Norway wanted a
little Norwegian boys saying you know
like when did you learn to stop crying
after a loss and Magnus looked at the
little boy and said what makes you think
I learned to stop crying